hi everyone ant-man and the wasp is now
in theatres giving us on any pity breath
the fresh air in these dark times of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and we are
here with our in-depth review how does
this movie compared to the first ant-man
and other relative standalone stories in
the MCU well welcome to new rockstars
news is there a deep dive into all the
biggest stories this week it's gonna be
mostly ant-man today but we're also
gonna talk about some things regarding
Star Wars Episode nine and we're gonna
talk about this this rumored fan edit
not Banat it Zack Snyder alternate edit
of Justice League does it exist is it
happening we'll talk about it
I'm Eric Bostrom at the table today or
Sam bash your filt molina in Maude
Garrett guys how is your week going real
quick can we just point out this is how
we're all doing right now can you see
that 113 degrees right now
113 that's how we're doing I do not get
it I'm not human so I measure degrees of
Kelvin and my phone is melted so we're
all like on a weird thing right now just
hang in there
you can see our sunburns by the way if
you look closely well let's power
through it start with our top story it's
a review of ant-man in the wasps now
it's best to consider this video as
spoiler review because we're gonna get
to all that lot twists and post-credit
scenes now unfortunately you're watching
this from the UK sorry the movie doesn't
come out for another month you can blame
the jocks who watch the World Cup which
is everyone in the UK
even though England's no longer in it
but hang tight who's the muted words
filters on social media there's ways
that you can protect yourself and I
highly suggest that you use them so you
don't come yelling us when we talk about
a movie that's still really popular the
rest of the world now I think we all had
things that we loved and things that we
maybe wanted more from a man in the wasp
so rather than just like wading into
some general opinions we have about I
want to try to narrow our opening
thoughts so as we get started I want
each of us to say one specific element
form Ant Man in the wasp that that the
movie brought to the MCU that you wish
other MCU movies did more of so how is
Emma in the wasp unique what did it do
that you
like oh that's the first time I've seen
that the bear you could say you could
say quantum anything quantum it says
that word a lot about that it's it
introduces a lot of new stuff that the
future movies can play with no I did and
I well you say we can say spoilers yeah
yeah we're talking about spoilers just
say that I felt the movie didn't quite
know what to even do with what it
introduced and it well uh sorry sorry I
think feel like we're gonna go down a
whole thing about what our issues are
and it's very easy because each of us
were talking earlier about like what our
issues are so I think like we need to
stay on the positive thing good on you
you get the award for this award for
Cassie because Cassie is adorable actor
she was in the first movie here but what
they introduced and this is the idea
that she could get her costume from the
comics cuz she's the character we she's
got like nine names the most popular
name is stature and she's part of the
Young Avengers and that could be a very
cool team yeah I mean for me I think one
thing this movie did really well was
like cleverly thought-out action you
know that's one thing I often missed
from some of the other MC movies they
have good action where it's exciting and
thrilling but they really did think
about like how can we be clever with
Scott Lang's shrinking and growing
problem I mean that whole sequence in
Cassie's school was one of the funniest
things I've seen and in the MCU just it
was a really fun extended gag that
created a lot of really fun sight visual
jokes that I really enjoyed and
throughout the movie I think it did a
really good job more than most other MC
movies really thinking about how can we
get the most mileage comedy wise out of
this action and this guy these gags yeah
I slightly will pick you back on yours
right I if you've ever seen my like Lego
Batman review thing I did a long time
ago it's called it which has a shared
writer actually as this movie has this
theory that I call if Totowa IFT t lava
t's w if this then what and I it adds a
comedic element always but what it is it
makes a list of like okay we have these
rules that are our fact these are true
now let's make a
everything else that could possibly be
true as an extension of that and so that
means that okay if you're this size and
they're and there are things with wheels
around you well isn't that true that
that would look to you like a skate or a
skateboard or a roller skate or
something so we could use it that way if
you can go any size then can't you go
awkward sizes like child size you know
like like so they that's what they're
doing there but then what I'll say could
happen across um to you cuz em so you
does a decent job with that is the way
that this movie does it with dialogue
also yeah and that's how you do get
lines which are very improper but
they're lines like so you can just put
quantum in front of everything whenever
like every time the Paul Rudd improvises
or it has that sound like he's
improvising really he's doing that same
exercise in his head of like if someone
really said this if this is really true
wouldn't I have this observation about
it like COD you guys say quantum wah I
wish the rest of them so you would do it
I also wish Star Wars would be okay with
that by the way yeah but yeah I again
the action was incredible and I loved
like the they don't have superpowers
technically it's all science-based think
about it but I love like that
supernatural feel behind it shrinking
growing and all the ways that you can
use it in action and in saying that I
think that Evangeline Lilly did a
spectacular job she was a favorite part
of this movie hands down she is the very
first Marvel female hero to be in the
title the name of a movie oh that's a
dream but that's absolutely fantastic
and she was so confident and so smart
and I think it's really lovely that you
know she's completely superior than Paul
Rudd's character yeah every way I think
is really really cool yeah I mean
Evangeline Lilly was fantastic at the
whole supporting cast like this is one
thing that actually they have in common
with mostly other MC movies is a
supporting cast of characters that often
overshadow the title hero Michael Payne
yeah I wish he did this before the movie
started that would've been amazing if
they did that same gag of him summing up
like a lot baby yeah what would his
example of like what would his
explanation be for what happened in
Germany or what happened he does say for
a second but you only see Evangeline
Lilly like on the street just like being
upset and it's like what if you like
actually right yeah
more than one side why don't they just
do that as like a web series or
something this needs be stringing up him
just like recapping every every Marvel
movie what's up listen I holiday what's
the name of the FBI agent actor Randall
Park Randall Terry was also so good so
him Michael Pena like I and then also
their interaction with Paul Rudd was so
hard to pull off and I thought I kept
being so impressed with like I didn't
expect that this would joke would work
and they always pull it off like the
joke it at the end when he's kind of
like you know I'll see you next time
he's like what and then they really go
down that path like do you wanna hang
out and you don't expect it to working
yet those actors are so good it's
another example with Jimmy woo when he's
like so you know if you get in trouble
at school by paying on them right good
daddy went to Germany like stinger for
that joke he's like you're great with
kids thanks I'm a youth pastor and I was
like yeah that's exactly how youth
pastors are like there you like them cuz
they're the pastor but there's so guard
like I was gonna say lame but they're
not laying I like them but you get what
I mean
yeah I think you know one struggle
Dempsey has had with making all these
standalone installments feel worthy
enough of their own movie despite not
having the world changing stake set of
interest movie have it's hard to keep
those stakes up and to feel like why
should I care about this story in
particular when the world's about to end
so I'm curious to hear from you guys how
do you think a man the wasp compared to
other Marvel's so side stories like you
know Doctor Strange or spider-man
homecoming or Black Panther even
guardians of the galaxy the first wonder
yeah of course the first fan man well
and I'll say actually because this was
my immediate reaction as soon as I saw
it a lot of people are gonna feel like
this is very similar to the first
ant-man movie and I know I was talking
some about how it it's not even like a
story about saving people you know like
like we got to go save some lives of
people being in hurry over it's like no
we messed up something we gotta fix it
kind of thing which feels like the first
maybe a bit but I think what they both
have in common and not everyone loves
this but what it's definitely sets it
apart from other like
kind of the side stories is it actually
is a side story yeah I mean like it is
not it doesn't really necessarily feel
like part of the MCU earlier with you I
was kind of comparing it to like it
could have been like game night right
like one of these movies that just comes
out that's like a high concept comedy
that's just like what if you could turn
big and small like like that movie that
you didn't love the Matt Damon you're
like they're many downsides
yeah downtown right but like it's just
like a high concept comedy and it could
work actually as an OP Marvel movie
without getting into the negativity I
would say it almost would be a better
non Marvel movie then as a Marvel movie
then it because of those disconnections
it is a little bit remember same world
same world I actually really loved the
first ant-man because it wasn't the end
of the world the end of the galaxy
I really liked that it was you know huge
stakes or something that was actually
quite small and I really love that
ant-man had smaller problems like I love
that kind of metaphor but in this one
yet it didn't pack as much of a punch I
had a lot more fleshed out but like the
actual purpose of this story I was like
okay alright and the ghost element was a
little bit tacked on to the side I feel
it don't feel like die
it's something trying to like not to go
negative yet we do we will do that but
that tacked on element it did feel right
like we were still waiting for like then
who's really in charge or something
because she didn't feel like the main
villain oh yeah for me I totally agree I
think that I've watched it twice now and
they did I liked it more the second time
and when we get into like ranking where
this is I think it's definitely better
than the first two Thor movies but I do
enjoy the first ain't man more and
actually there's a middle part of the
movie where you learn everything about
ghosts and if you took that out it goes
from really funny like sneaking into
where ghost is and it's one of my I love
the Joker he's like where they come up
to ghost house and they're like yeah
that's right like it is like place it
out in the woods like of course she's
gonna be there and that cuts to Luis and
Sonny doing the interview the
interrogation scene which is a maze
truth serum yeah and like if they kind
of just took out that ghost part like it
would have been a shorter movie and you
kind of could have kept going it would
have made it perfect but her stuff just
like it kind of felt like when she would
come on screen you get like she wasn't
that intimidating which sucks because
her her stuff was so cool not getting
negative that it is lower on my list
because when it kind of hit her some of
the story started to like they try to
add like a time element of like we're
gonna run out of time right don't do
this this and this and there are three
different things that are supposed to be
lined up but they don't it doesn't feel
like anything's actually gonna happen it
feels like kind of like we should do it
because this person has a gun to my head
that's about it but also like the
mission is to save one person's life and
it's like whose life is more important
one person or another one person I mean
you know these characters have to be
someone we do know that one of them's
bad so it's kind of like yeah I think
that's really what separates this this
standalone installment from the other
ones that we've seen is even if it's not
connected to the broader narrative of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe you can
kind of get by that if you really imbue
your protagonists with like a clear want
and a clear goal that you can get on
board with and if you can remove even
Scott Lang from this story and just
focus on the wasp and her goal to
reunite with her mother and Hank Pym
school to reunite with his wife yeah
that's a story I can get behind
unfortunately Scott Lang just felt so
deep oured in the movie I mean literally
as a character but also in terms of his
activeness in the story I compared him
to someone like Black Panther even dr.
strange you knew what they wanted out of
the movie so there's kind of that clear
through line so you're able to track it
and keep and follow it and root for the
character to win by the end of it and I
just didn't see that with Scott Lang in
this movie and that I think that's one
thing that kind of separates if you're
not feeling that same kind of adoration
for this chapter that you maybe felt for
some of those others that might be one
reason why he's got some amazing parts
but it like the scene when he with Janet
face but not which and but with Janet
when it's amazing he nailed that scene
and he has a great community Allen but
yet you're right he did feel be powered
he also felt dumber like as a whole like
it is quantise he's an electrical
engineer and he worked at another like a
company it's a little foggy when they
kind of said what his whole backstory is
but like this is not his wheelhouse and
it's fine that he doesn't know but
overall he kind of felt like incapable
of figuring out like a problem he just
had catch him up every time yeah he's so
clueless yeah well I mean we've been
doing a good job holding ourselves back
this is not a perfect movie let's talk
about some of the gripes said we had
with this movie what would you want two
more of from this movie or maybe less of
what what was something that like ah not
to complain because we can't very good
like we we break down trailers and it's
fun to break down trailers but because
we watch all the trailers we saw the
action it was one didn't happen that we
didn't see the giant version of him in
the ocean was kind of like yeah that was
cool and actually that's one of my
favorite jokes when he's like and I like
funny but like you saw you knew that
wasn't a surprise like when you saw his
feet we regardless if we saw that in a
trailer or not we would have known what
that was it would have been funnier with
Tim Heidecker and that scene it's it was
a bummer that all of the action was
spoiled and also when ghosts would show
up she'd just kind of like yeah wave a
face and it's just like if it didn't
feel like fighting they did get really
creative with it but we already knew
what that was going into it so the movie
didn't have as much like surprise
elements to it was kind of like going
through the motions and it kind of the
this movie fell back into like the
villain problem where it's like ghosts
you you told us what's wrong
but I don't care and like sunny it's
like you're just in them way you're you
are exactly Justin Hammer from Iron Man
two same teeth and all like everything
like same tan everything like he's a
great actor Walton Goggins he kind of
looks like a name it's great name you
know so if you took Ghost Rider and if
you like put a fan up to his hair and
they like start moving around and then
you just took off how do you know this I
want to piggyback off something Sam said
so I'll go to my things that I think are
issues I think there there are a number
of issues and I think I'm
focus on to that just so you guys can
talk about other stuff but related to
the fight things that you were just
saying
not only were they spoiled for us but
also they were it's a kind of bad
pairing with the phasing and the
shrinking every single fight felt like
all potential energy and then wasted
right everything felt like a Miss it was
constantly like I go through you or I
shrink and think about how many times it
felt like a punch landed and it's so low
and it turned out I don't know I
actually learned this by watching this
movie that I need punches to land in
order to feel that a fight is happening
otherwise I feel like we're narrowly
avoiding a fight constantly it's like
music without a drumbeat right socata so
it it was so easy for me to think like
you have two very fascinating power
powers going on but why is it that if
you think for a moment about a fight in
daredevil with just people that are just
like good at fighting and that
difference is action directing right the
directing of a fights a lot of the
issues of some people have with a lot of
versions of Batman movies to where it's
like if they don't nail the fight
moments then they actually like you
don't feel the fight so we did not feel
the fights and then the only other thing
that I'll kind of just throw out there
and I'll be the first one to say it is
like the quantum entanglement it's just
kind of like it felt like we need a plot
device so how do we it's very hard to
figure out how can we get her back I
totally got that the thing they came up
with was essentially like a Freaky
Friday okay it's hard whoa and
interstellar at least like I'm like like
yeah you know what there's a 5th
dimension thing and they really like
built up to it over this kind of was
like he's in the bathtub is it good oh
now I have a psychic link with her and
it that felt just a little too easy I
think for me one of my
I think yet called the quantum sequence
I didn't care and like you know she had
a lot of makeup on for being lost for
thirties whatever I noticed that to the
eyeliner specifically and I was like you
know what she didn't clean it for thirty
years also like she's wearing robes that
she didn't go down with know where that
came from also she turned her wings into
swords sorry go on
yeah but for me like the big problem was
when I did the press to it for this one
and the question the number one question
everyone had going into this was where
does it sit in the timeline and they
were not equipped with an answer and the
fact that they were like I was like
great I know the cutscene I know the end
scene which is tough they needed to just
kind of I don't know dangle the
different carrot or smoke and mirrors
with it but the fact that they were like
the number one thing number one question
everyone's to know they weren't equipped
with the particular answer for it and I
remember saying like going into this
movie and going I absolutely can
guarantee you one of the end scenes is
going to be to do with yeah I kept
saying that it was gonna be his daughter
like now that we've seen it I think it's
so just like Daddy are I adorable yeah I
agree I think there was a lot of issues
I had when it came to like just
answering the question you know and like
why not just like answer where it sits
in the timeline right they just said
present day was like right after the the
title cards like you've got to
understand who's watching your movie
it's people who for whom present day
it's like no we have a million more
questions also like you oh you establish
I think the critical minute or the
critical minutes of the movie are the
first minutes right that's where you
make the promise Liana this is what the
movies gonna be they open with the scene
where it's pretty much just Hank Pym and
hope discussing what the plan is rolling
out the blueprints and then we spend an
hour and 45 minutes not doing that doing
every other thing other than that we try
to do it for a second it's it's unclear
exactly why they can't take those steps
tonight and then once we finally rescue
Janet Van Dyne I have a million
questions
how is this affected her emotionally how
is she survived what is she eaten she
does even tardigrades we were so
fascinated but I'll give you I'm gonna
give you a fix I think that could have
made this
work a lot better and I normally I'm not
this pretentious about this yeah so I
the issue that you just described right
they start with a plan to get her mother
back and then we watch an entire movie
that is about roadblocks to the existing
plan right you know would be a lot more
interesting reasons why they should not
do their own plan right I'm gonna go and
I'm gonna save my wife even if it means
I'm gonna end up killing people or
something like if he has to deal with
the fact that like kind of we talked
about earlier right it was such an easy
choice oh if we bring her back villain
might die it's like yeah that's fine
what if like bringing her back could
kill his daughter or something right
it's like who do you love more your
daughter your wife like or just these
kind of like things that make it hard to
do but instead it was like literal
roadblocks right just like tables all
over like you have that's how ghost gets
introduced like I thought it was so
weird that like she's big create ghosts
that way yeah weird what if she exists
she existed how is everything that them
opening the quantum realm once but
immediately she could feel it
accelerating really fastest yeah but I
didn't have a plan to fix it they were
like you just need to stop doing that or
I'm literally going to be ripped apart
but then you get two arguments you're
like we don't want to kill a person but
also she's murdered so many people
before and she's maybe not a good person
deep down and right bill foster you can
kind of throw out the movie I like
Laurence Fishburne but he's kind of like
is it was not a good reveal and it
wasn't really important but like there
could have been like some stakes also
why was she doing this now why is she
only gonna die in a few weeks if they're
like which is kind of convenient
actually right I mean and you know what
interesting answer maybe it was because
they started the quantum tunnel they
didn't say that but that would have been
would have been great I don't like when
you can solve the problems of a movie by
the writer just stroking his pennis
light a different way it's like Oh turns
out ghosts and her thing isn't going on
in China and it'll take her longer than
two days to get there so they'll have
finished their thing and I've been fine
yeah it's it's tough you know there was
a lot of writers on this movie and it
did really feel like something that was
put together through just like a team
bonding exercise there was a lot of
amazing well-written sequences in the
movie some great dialogue some great
jokes but it just felt like a lot of
different good elements coming together
in the film that didn't all work
harmoniously and one
clerestory with a clear theme like what
message do we take away from the
character's journey in this movie I have
no idea no there was one other thing I
wanted to mention like a lot of people
asked if you want to know more about
Jane offend and she can't do that
whatever happened like that she know
she's like based on UT right I think
you're forgetting that's from nothing
and it just felt like this weird other
element like it didn't make any sense
for what they established from the
quantum realm or or it could have with
its own context that Eric was kind of
just saying right give us new context
she said it's evolution from having been
in the quantum realm that sounds like a
more interesting movie honestly words
like she stayed there she found a way to
survive by eating tardigrade or whatever
it is but whatever her way she's
surviving and she's going through
changes and honestly like that's a
version that they tried to do with
Doctor Doom in the Fantastic Four reboot
if they totally like failed with because
they also did the same thing we're like
and he stayed a long time so he kind of
like is messed up now and they also
skipped that but it's like the
transformations that a person's going
through especially psychologically if
she's crazy now that'd be fascinating
they bring back and she's a little dark
P dimensional person so it's like his
mind right the way I just remember
telling him to do it and they're his
slaves but they don't have the joints to
hold it this way oh and they're just
minions credits scene was a little out
of touch tonally it was like here's John
of the Dead but the ants don't like the
drums and will be until the end of the
second post-credit decision will get to
the post-credits scenes later this
episode so yeah in the comments down
below let us know your thoughts about
this movie do you disagree with any of
our points or there anything that you
feel like we missed the real reason why
I didn't work out we we want this to be
a conversation with you let
know your thoughts in the comments a
little but for now let's move on to this
week's trivia question oh and it is
about its man and the wasp and it's how
many ants who is counting okay so here
we go in ant-man and the wasp what card
from the playing card deck did Scott
Lang pull out of Cassie's ear while
demonstrating a magic trick for FBI
agent Jimmy woo okay all of our answers
are in this pocket here and two sirs and
the closest ant sir will judges will do
our sign-off good-byes at the end of the
video all the loser will have to
cleverly rip on our in other news
headlines but let us move on guys we
actually will get to more ant-man
discussion a bit but first a quick news
update that just came out today
according to reports actress Keri
Russell is in talks to play a role in
Star Wars Episode nine yeah Russell just
finished the FX series of the Americans
which is amazing she's so good and she
is so yeah she's great in it and being
in the next service movie would reunite
her with director JJ Abrams whom she
worked with on a show Felicity and
Mission Possible three where she had the
best like death Ethan Erin are weirdly
obsessed with that my mind bomb that
blows sideways Tom Cruise somehow gets
hit by a missile from behind in 90
degrees okay but let's return to our
discussion of ant-man in the wise to
pass with the accent for me I'm sorry
okay everyone let's talk about the
post-credits scenes of ant-man in the
wasp now spoiler warning obviously we
haven't seen the movie yet specifically
let's talk about how what we saw in the
post-credits scene could set things up
for Avengers for now a Sam broke down
the post-credits scenes in another video
that you should definitely go check out
but just to recap quickly the first
mid-credits scene shows Scott Lang
entering the quantum realm to gather
some quantum healing energy but then he
gets trapped in the quantum realm when
hope and Frank and Janet
dusted out of existence it's the
immediate aftermath of thanasis snap at
the end of infinity war probably we'll
see now the post second post credit
scene is a little more straightforward
it shows Scott's empty house with an
emergency broadcast signal on the TV and
an oversized aunt playing drums that we
saw in the trailer now okay to me there
are a few interesting things to note
from these scenes first the idea that
Scott is trapped in the quantum realm
how will he get out does he have a spare
Pym particle on him will Captain Marvel
so now play a role in his rescue and
actually if you're listening closely
before he went through into the quantum
tunnel Janet Warren Scott not to get
trapped into a time vortex while he's
down there a time vortex and does the
quantum realms laws of physics allow
wormholes through time is that what
we're gonna be seen in Avengers 4
there's also the idea of multiple
realities now earlier in the movie
during Bill Foster's lecture on quantum
mechanics he mentions the idea of
tinkering with these kinds of physics
could cause chaos that could cause
multiple realities I'm curious to hear
you guys theories about what's next for
Scott and how these clues could connect
to the ending of this movie to Avengers
4 he's in the current guardians of
galaxies right now he's great he's very
funny how do you think I'll get there
this in the video it's like if you one
time went down the corner room by
accident mm-hmm and you happen to find
an accidental way how to get out of
there and someone's like can you go down
there again it's like yeah but I'm gonna
take a bunch of the emergency exit stuff
that's cool they wouldn't have told him
no and so he can just go and can't get
out of there maybe yeah I'm gonna get is
that it might you might not be that
might not be an option of how to get out
of there like there might the way to get
out of the quantum realm I be parter
than that I know he should have gone
down on the ship by the way but I'm
gonna throw out the most bummer version
of it because I want to get it out of
the way well how this easily could play
out right
we have just put him down to the quantum
room and then we have this really
interesting question like how does he
get out how does he help the vendors in
the next infinity war movie and then
maybe he just doesn't and then the next
movie happens and then they unsnap
people or however they're gonna bring
the rest of the characters back and then
um they just they just bring him back
like normal like they did and they're
like woo boy that was a hard two-week
sort of like like there's no reason to
guarantee that they will bring him out
of the quantum realm to help with
infinity war right now I think that's
like the question on people's mind and
you know there's how much you want to
look at these set photos but they're out
there now there's these I stand
completely corrected I don't look at set
photos because I don't like getting
spoiled and that's yeah I mean and I try
to avoid it too but I mean you guys are
great about sweet thing we've made a
couple videos about it looks like
they're wearing watches I don't really
know what to make of it but then in a
recent video I did I'm like wait aren't
those watches or those Pym particles
around their eyes because they don't
look like watches they do look more like
clump particles I I do think the quantum
realm is being set up as some kind of
way to defeat things and I don't think
she would have said time vortex I don't
think the writers I don't think [ __ ]
would have put that in there if it
didn't have an importance later just
saying yeah I mean that was really good
I don't remember the words
yeah he said this is the this is the
only way or there was no other way and
we're in the endgame now I handed over
the time stone okay and an endgame game
you play games with balls balls are
similar to particles Pym particles and
then we're there in the nine eleven yeah
and then Kevin fry bacon yeah I think in
some ways these post-credits scenes are
more like carefully crafted than many
parts of the movies themselves because I
think Feige knows like how critically
the audience is watched those looking
for creative I feel like they get told
like here's some things you got a hit
and then you guys still get to write it
because I think had they been a little
bit more on top of it
tonally or something they would have
realized like hey this first post credit
scene Thanos has attacked like New York
is under
there's like war in Wakanda with an
alien invasion like a lot of crazy stuff
is going on and they're like joking
about the horn or on the roof like that
we saw the moment of the snap not the
moment when Thanos like gets to earth
said oh no they just seem like very out
of touch with what's probably on the
news well there was that whole like
timeline thing at the Avengers defending
the war post-credits scene right like in
fury and Cobie Smulders character we're
hearing about this news and then like
maybe thirty seconds later they just it
seems like there's like a delay in
communication and they're in
communication I think honestly like this
that's kind of gonna be an in world
solution to a thing that they're not
nailing out of the world we're just like
how much time passed between this and
this and why did people like sometimes
not know anything about it or sometimes
spend a movies worth of time treasure I
think that's one of these things that
might be plans flood somewhere it's like
I'm still gonna do the plans yeah like a
cascading effect of like people are like
trying to like get into a good situation
before I don't know yeah I think one I
mean regardless of how logically they
get to these next steps I love this
emergency broadcast signal right like
that yeah it's totally set this really
interesting tone tone tone tone Quan
tone like this is the reality we're now
in yeah right it's like a zombie
apocalypse or an alien strike two-word
they don't even have television
broadcasting - yeah in a previous video
either that I wanted a post-credits
scene or I wanted somewhere maybe it's
beginning in the next movie or something
but exactly what that emergency
broadcasting implies which is what
happens to the infrastructure of the
world when half of the people disappear
and again it's that the show the
leftovers is a whole freakin serious I
don't like 2% in the leftover yeah
exactly it's like I I'm so fascinated I
could have a whole movies worth of just
like how does the world deal with half
of the people on it are gone yeah yeah
oh it's amazing
ha yeah yeah I it also statistically
didn't hehe just like wipeout like
possibly like whole like jobs like from
people like some people have very
specific people who run nuclear plants
like he could have statistically don't
have and also there's no one running any
nuclear plants anymore right or like I
mean the chances that he did take out
both pilots of an airplane like is very
like military in a case you saw right
exactly so it's just like I want to see
that but extrapolate it all the way
through to cakes being dropped in the
street now only being carried by one guy
and it's a smaller one probably it's the
one that okay I got it I got it it's
just like that mama strength when the
baby gets caught under the cars flew
into it well you shouldn't need a baby
anyway for the car well below how you
think these post-credits scenes might
connect to the opening shots Avengers
four are we gonna see everything get
used in a specific way or is it some of
it's just stuff that I am I decided to
like throw in there just to set a tone
okay another news update from this week
let's talk about these rumors about
Justice League in which fans are
speculating that original director Zack
Snyder has been working on his own
director's cut of the movie without
Warner Brothers the theatrical release
that we saw of course was finished by
Joss Whedon he took over for Zack Snyder
halfway through production when Snyder
had to step down for family related
reasons but fans have demanded that
Snyder released his complete vision and
despite the rumors and reports and
Snyder tending actually like tweets of
fans who asked for a director's cut he's
very active on Twitter other people who
have worked on the movie have said that
these headlines are just clickbait and
that there is no Snyder cut that exists
and you know if you know how movies are
made when Snyder's step down midway
through production due to his family
issues he didn't complete a full cut of
the movie and Warner Brothers didn't ask
for reshoots they brought in a director
to finish the parts of the movie that
we're not done yet
so there's no alternate better version
of the movie that's out there that's
been hidden from you so I don't know
let's just let the versions of movies
that are given to us be what they are
and stop demanding
that people change things in general I'm
just gonna say I actually did throw a
conspiracy twist on the same hat I'm
already wearing I there was a Schneider
cut because it's a version he screened
and there were early responses to it and
they specifically said like it's a movie
already that the effects aren't finished
on but this is Snyder's cut of the movie
so a Snyder cut exists but what has just
not been it's not a movie they do not
they talked specifically about a
screened version that was not missing
huge chunks it was his cut it was just
unfinished scenes but it was the length
of the movie the new chunks are new
before the Joss Whedon rewrite I
I think the version that they're talking
about is filled in it's not a complete
movie and I don't think you would like
it more and I think we need to stop
today because I think it's we go down a
dangerous path and we tell people like
you're being withheld information it's
just accept the movie as it is right I
don't care if I sound like I'm she lord
of the deep stated both that people keep
saying change it yeah for a while and
it's like it wasn't that he'd wanted to
step away from the project think it was
it's tragic yeah yeah it was like his
priorities were completely in order but
yeah it's something that you'd put all
your energy into someone else to go away
yeah but I'm gonna skew it a little bit
like and then it gets terrible reviews
you might you might actually be like oh
if only but there's also no way of
knowing anything from anything and
there's gonna be no more money that goes
into completing the scenes that they
already shot unless Zack Snyder wants to
pay for that that's his business but for
the most part for your part you just
stop asking for it because it's
nothing's gonna happen you guys
protested outside of DC that didn't do
anything this is how movies are made
pretty much every movie you see started
with one writer they took it from that
writer passed up to the other writers
should we expect every writer of every
movie made for a big-budget movie to
release their version of the script and
their version movie that was in their
vision this doesn't belong to any one
person this is accent yeah I mean it and
the way to under had a whole different
cut of
later but just because it has happened
in the past I think it creates as
dangerous precedent where we don't buy
anything that's just given to us it has
to be we want to know every single
ultimate version that's out there just
because we don't like it I guarantee you
Zack Snyder's version of Justice League
was not as good as a version that was
released in theaters and I think that's
a different discussion and I actually am
less am a place with you both of you
really on that one where it's like are
you waiting for a better movie and stop
waiting that's not out there is there a
possibility that the original director
had a different version than the final
director absolutely is there a
possibility that he might even have
interest and showing what his original
vision was absolutely is it gonna be
better
bye we'll give it 10 years and then you
can ask and then no one will care and
they'll give it to you if we also
reshoots aren't a bad thing by the way
that just happens in movies it's a lot
there's budget allotted for you to do
reshoots in a movie just so we can clear
that all up you're welcome are okay
everyone ant-man and the wasp is unique
actually among Marvel movies in the way
that the villain plays in the story not
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
movie yet but yeah ant-man's marketing
setup ghosts probably to be the
antagonist but halfway through the
movies she switched to a more
sympathetic figure and that left Walter
Goggins as Sonny birch an arms dealer to
be kind of a bad guy but even he seemed
to be kind of a smaller threat within
the stakes of the story now he did hint
early in the movie that he works for
very dangerous people and they left us
wondering who could be his boss who does
Sonny birch work for is this something
that's important are we gonna see this I
thought it could be interesting to run
through a couple options of how Sonny
Bert's could tie a villain from the past
or maybe one that we haven't seen yet
into the future the MCU in the Marvel
comics is worth knowing that marvel that
Sonny Burch is more of a corporate
villain to Tony Stark he works for the
cross technologies company he's actually
affiliated with Obadiah Stane the
villain from Iron Man played by Jeff
Bridges
now stain could be the dangerous arm
stealer mastermind behind the curtain
here desperate to get his hands on Hank
Pimm's lab but the last we saw him he
definitely seemed to die in a fire yeah
that one fun fact though actually the
original script had I'm not dying
he was gonna like he was gonna get out
run away and like been there like now I
will let him die but you could still
have that I mean he will have to have
bridges back absolutely we've got new
technology to help people yeah mm-hmm
yeah there's yeah there's also we're
talk about arm stealers it's Justin
Hammer who is still alive is Sam
Rockwell's character he's left in Sea
Gate prison along with Trevor Slattery
that was the actor who poses the
Mandarin in Iron Man 3 I I think if we
were gonna see an arms you know that
would be I don't know you had some
issues just in a hammer as I change it
though it's just interesting that he
ended up in the same prison as Luke Cage
that's where he was and hammer tech was
a big part of season 1 and 2 of Luke
Cage it's kind of funny little fact yeah
now organizations like Huayra and shield
Hydra sorry I missed it either and
they're both currently in shambles like
Hydra is kind of splintered into a bunch
of smaller groups on the show agents of
shield so I don't know they would play
into this unless there's some other kind
of side group that they spawned into but
there's also option of characters like
Norman Osborn right now that's a Spider
Man is halfway in the MCU and in the
Sony verse perhaps Spider Man far from
home the the second movie will feature
the tech arms developer in some capacity
maybe with a desire to weaponize the
shrinking technology I know would you
guys be interested in seen could be cool
it would be I would be down for that he
plays a really big role in Bendis is
like New Avengers stuff he ends up
running one of the like he runs The
Avengers at one point he that's where
the iron patriot came from that cost him
from Iron Man 3 he wore that and like so
he has a bigger role in the in Marvel
Comics and that would be a really cool
next villain to kind of go into because
he's extremely capable yeah yeah I'll
give you just a very different idea
we're entering a new phase of Marvel
entirely right like we have to be
preparing now for the other side of
infinity war but also for the other side
of a Disney Fox merger I feel like they
could it purposely be leaving a little
open be like you know what maybe we can
reveal a character we don't currently
have the rights to in the one I'll throw
right now is Doctor Doom yeah who is a
character who had never been nailed
but who if you go through the comics is
actually like one
significant characters in the entire
Marvel Universe so you know and he'd be
he'd have interested in quantum type
potentially like so III do think that
it's my guess is like maybe it's
purposely being my vague and they're
gonna plug that later yeah or a mole man
and he there's there's probably an
easier way to do this we could he steal
this building lab for me well let us
know what you think about is there a
future villainous group that may be
teased and ant-man in the wasp or what
kind of villains from the comics do you
think should be brought into the MCU and
now is the time to move on to our new
rockstars news lightning round
114 degrees right now
station is possible
[Music]
at kcg filio says what would you name
your ant companion aunt honey hopkins
anthony daniels i guess it's either bo
Carmelo Anthony or Kobe Bryant he gave a
lot of good mods gonna come up with
their own because that was just showing
off his own yeah I know well done
Antonio Antonio Phillip at Bruce Game
Freak wants to know who oh this actually
who should be the next MCU major villain
after Thanos and he already said Doctor
Doom so if not Doctor Doom Mephisto oh
sure mr. uh uh basically the devil right
like like you you have all these these
characters that are like oh now I have
this reason I have this reason I have
these reasons like I'm the devil I'm the
devil
oops I'm the death try to fight me and I
got em oh man
we could get Galactus I gotcha small man
team up would be interesting I can't
figure out how to do Galactus and it's
not a cloud and it's not a giant keeping
a Bullwinkle man Sam at books of KT if
you were on death row what would your
last meal be and what would you do you
just gave me like a good old drama
nutella let me work through that bad boy
and when they get me with the Lightning
cap lightning round be great be fun like
Clayface like Sandman find out next week
on humanity uh cool so Eric from at true
score its court or trues corn Eric you
have become a super villain oh you're
like we're playing a game right now all
right
Eric you have become a super villain
your gimmick is based on the things that
are currently in your pocket man what is
your villain name and what is you evil
plan
what is your seat - Wayne and who this
was okay so the it's no it's a 70s bar
in Hollywood good time to Davey wavey
and then we got a disco stu and a black
magic woman so that would be my disco
stu is my name yeah no relation to
simpsons yeah oh yeah oh yeah I know
really should and then and then what
would my power be yeah black magic black
magic woman would be my power and how
does that work
sir II suppose up and works their magic
well I've seen your like charm she's
magic Cole's gonna be like Dazzler too
you could shoot the Disco stuff out of
your hands Yeah right and yeah I might
and your servers name is Geoffrey with
the GE it was the choice Geoffrey who
write drinks is who sever days he's out
of work now lightning round
we need a new mascot Geoffrey do you
want to be as Oh questions and keep an
eye out for a tweet next week so you can
get your tweet and your handle mentioned
in this episode and ask us whatever you
want but next let's take a look at what
we got in the pipeline for videos coming
out on this channel in the next week of
course we have our full breakdown of
ant-man and the wasps we'll also be
releasing our first of our three-part
series of the Christopher Nolan Dark
Knight trilogy
Batman Begins is check out our trailer
that we did for this one of my favorite
things we put on our Channel edited by
Devin Devin
did a killer job on that that trailer is
so cool just check it out and we'll put
a link in the description and and card
yeah and then the week after that we'll
be doing our breakdown of the Dark
Knight which I'm currently finishing up
right now and it's gonna be as good if
not better than and begins the way the
movie was so really enjoy this I'm very
excited about this I think guys will
like it and we'll have some other
projects that just keep an eye out
comic-con is just around the corner and
we'll have a Aquaman and Wonder Woman
stuff coming out but now comes the time
for our 15-second shout out where each
of us is 15 seconds to shout out a plug
or ramble about anything Sam okay if you
have always liked the comics it's like
we you just pick one up and here's one
you could pick up Superman number one
written by Brian Michael Bendis and if
you know that name or if you don't sound
familiar he created Jessica Jones and
everything you like about Luke Cage he
created that too he's a very good writer
it's his new story with Superman it's a
brand new everything so if you want to
hop into that go check it out comes up
next Wednesday Oh hmm for my 15 seconds
you can check out the movie sorry to
bother you which I'm gonna try to see
this week it was a trailer it looks
really good
and I you know I can't personally
recommend because I've been seeing it
but it looks really really good it's got
the guy from like get out and yeah
Thompson Terry Crews Armie Hammer
there's a lot of big actors about it I
do yeah you do well let's all go watch
it together
how about that Philip Mudd a piece of
Janet Van Dyne different genres on
different platforms and it starts off
from like the very first sort of PC all
the way through the crown consoles and
I've been pouring hours into it and so
that's my recommend a
how's your it's like game eyeballs
scratched by whatever is in there that's
cool it looks like you're winking yeah I
can't me my 15-second shadow are to self
love and care download a meditation app
or start going to therapy or just be
nice to yourself it's really important
and it makes you feel good allow
emotions to be communicated and you have
to repress nothing to joke with about
that even though her eyes thing is
ridiculous
download headspace is a good meditation
yeah these are good recommendation just
to remind you what the question was it
was what card from the playing card deck
did Scott Lang pull out of his daughter
Cassie's ear and let's get on a line and
see what we said this fimo drew it Ace
of Hearts Ace of Hearts Maud said the
eight of Hearts
alright Sam said the ace of spades okay
- said the Ace of Hearts Ace of Spades
the other ones we were pretty equal but
this one is an eight eight so neither is
the number oh you're right sorry I
misread
yes my boys Sam you actually get your
goodbyes but would you also like to read
the news headline setups as well yeah so
yeah you guys know how this goes we'll
have a news headline mazda has to
cleverly riff on it so Sam take it away
we'll Jew number one in the upcoming
Captain Marvel movie samuel l.jackson
will be digitally d aged 25 years to
play a younger Nicholas Fury but he
hasn't aged in the last 25 years anyway
[Music]
number two Fox is working Hawks on a TV
series spin-off
from the alien movie franchise I'm just
still caught up on how you guys say Fox
no we don't he just said I said Fox he
said it was a you sounds like a naughty
word that's magic yeah alright and
number three Walking Dead actor Jeffrey
Dean Morgan told fans to knock it off
was shown up at his house and knocking
on his door
Jeffrey Dean no gun yet but if you keep
doing that get off my lawn Oh Jeffrey
Dean door gone
for a subreddit called Thanos did
nothing wrong there's always plans to
randomly ban half its members life finds
a way
oh yeah
Netflix plans to disable Oh online
written reviews for its content
keeping only the thumbs up or the thumbs
down recommendation
check this out thank you so much for
watching
Dease week of new rock stars news well I
think our hosts am Eric Phil Mudd
comment down below and tweet Avenue rock
stars at new rock stars like various
shared round with friend subscribe to
new rock stars deep ties Niles I feel
love make sure you at the notification
bell so you can keep up to date with all
the videos that come up see you next
time bye well done Sam that is not what
I talk like it's pretty good oh wait we
got to do the sign the card
oh wow that didn't go anywhere was that
yeah